now that we have the tile Jason loaded
we need to parse it so let's take a
closer look at the structure of this
file there's a few things that should
interest you about this file right away
first is the initial parameters
discussing the size of the tiles that
this map expects the second is the
number of vertical and horizontal tiles
used for instance the width parameter
here defines that this map is 100 tiles
wide of course the total size of the map
in pixels is width times tile width or
64 pixels per tile giving you 6400
pixels
secondly you'll notice that there's a
section devoted to what Atlas is this
map uses called tile sets this section
will list for each Atlas the image
location given the absolute path from
the editor as well as the width and
height of the input images any
particular names or properties that
you've attached to the Atlas and most
importantly first GID which we'll get
into in a minute while we're parsing our
layer data finally we have a separate
section of the JSON file devoted to the
layers that you've defined now each
layer that exists has a data element
which actually lists out a large very
large ludicrously large array of integer
values that represent each tile that
you've placed on this layer of course
this layer also has other properties
like the height in number of tiles as
well as the opacity and then any other
information like the name and whether or
not this tile is visible this type
parameter is also interesting because
tiled allows you to have both tile
layers and object layers of course this
layer you're looking at is defined as a
tile layer